the chicken is awesomely beautiful on
top and crispy it was my most popular
dish hi tasty i'm chef lex and i was a
chef in the nba bubble
today i'll be teaching you how to make
my crack buffalo mac and cheese a
favorite of many of the players i've
been a private chef now for about five
years in the athlete sector i knew i had
to be a part of this because this is
history i probably sent about 100 emails
all my friends tagging the nba jeff
likes it she has it you guys need to
hire her the passion was there i was
ready for this opportunity eventually
i got the call
i was floored when they saw all my
preparation
they offered me the opportunity to come
into the bubble and cook at the
executive chef kitchen when i arrived
the kitchen was completely bare all we
had was pots and pans so we set up the
kitchen literally from the ground up the
comfort kitchen menu was a summation of
everything the guys were not getting i
could have came in and did healthy food
but that was what disney was already
doing i wanted them to be able to call
comfort kitchen and get a piece of
cornbread and some catfish and wanted
them to feel their own kitchen at home
was just a phone call away the one thing
that i never changed off the menu was my
buffalo chicken mac and cheese honestly
i think you guys are going to love it
too
to make my crack buffalo mac and cheese
you want to start with bechamel i start
mine by melting the butter in a heavy
bottom saucepan then i take my flour and
i just mix the flour and the butter
together
gently on a low heat till it creates
small bubbles and starts to make a soft
roux then you want to add some warm milk
adding more milk to the mixture helps to
homogenize the butter and flour roux so
that it thickens a lot faster you'll
want to add a bay leaf and let that
simmer cook your brush melt down until
it begins to thicken you'll know you're
there if you can run your finger down
the back of a spoon and your finger
streak will hold its position next we'll
be making our fried chicken you want to
start by placing two cups of oil in a
saucepan and putting it over a medium
heat in a bowl you want to place your
six ounce piece of chicken along with
one tablespoon of your all-purpose
seasoning some cayenne pepper just a
pinch and about one tablespoon of lemon
juice in a medium mixing bowl we'll add
together our flour and cornmeal and corn
starch along with half a tablespoon of
all-purpose seasoning in a separate
mixing bowl we'll be combining
buttermilk
one tablespoon of all-purpose seasoning
and you want to mix that well and then
add your chicken you want to let that
sit for about two to three minutes and
then remove your chicken from this
mixture and add it to your dredge we
want a real crispy crunchy coating on
this chicken so we're gonna let it sit
in the flour mixture and we're going to
spoon some more flour over it and let
the buttermilk soak up all of the
cornmeal flour next we'll be removing
our chicken and dusting off whatever
excess dredge is not sticking before you
put the chicken into your oil you'll
definitely want to test it with some of
your flour mixture take a pinch of it
and toss it into your saucepan
if it starts bubbling back at you your
oil is hot enough add your chicken to
the oil about two to three minutes in
turn your chicken over to make sure you
get an even cooking on each side and
we're looking for a nice golden brown
color
after about five to six minutes in the
fry oil we'll want to remove our chicken
and let rest either on a fry rack or
paper towel you want to make sure that
your fried chicken is golden brown on
the outside
as well as having an internal
temperature of 165 degrees this fried
chicken recipe was especially popular
amongst the la clippers nothing could
prepare me for what it was actually like
being isolated i was in the bubble for
about two and a half months some of the
things that you really start to miss are
as simple as getting a hug seeing
friends people that know you and care
you're around all these people but you
can't engage and you miss that lastly
we're gonna get these mac and cheese
noodles ready we're going to boil our
cavitavi in heavily salted water for
about five to six minutes
we want to make sure that our noodles
are al dente because they will continue
cooking in the mac and cheese
and we don't want them soggy after our
noodles are boiled we want to drain them
and toss them lightly in oil you're
going to add one and a half cups of your
bechamel sauce
and some salt cracked black pepper
quarter cup mozzarella cheese
a quarter cup extra sharp yellow cheddar
and a quarter cup sharp white cheddar
a quarter cup of buffalo sauce and half
of your chopped up chicken mix this
together well and we're going to put it
into a pre-sprayed glass baking dish
cover the top of the mac and cheese the
rest of your shredded cheese to make it
extra special i add the rest of my
chopped up fried chicken on top with
just a touch more cheese to give depth
and crispiness to our finished products
bake that for about 15 minutes at 400
degrees or until the top of the cheese
is golden brown
you'll notice the golden brown
bubbliness all around the edges the
chicken awesomely beautiful on top and
crispy nice tender chunks on the inside
as well as creamy mac and cheese feel
free to drizzle some more buffalo sauce
on top or even blue cheese if that's
your preference please this recipe is
not for try
time for the taste test
can't wait to take a bite and enjoy
the mba was leaving no room for error as
much as it was intense it's the reason
why every single person
on campus stayed safe and covered free
and it's the same reason why the players
could play at the level they did and
we saw the playoffs to the end it's the
reason the chefs could cook and the
media could do their job we all had to
make sacrifices but the overall greater
good of the sacrifice it was just epic
of course i would do it again this time
in my life will be a story i tell my
grandkids and great grandkids one day
god willing
oh yes
[Music]
you